>> Judge Jeanine: GAS PRICES
ARE STARTING TO RISE AGAIN AT
THE BIDEN PROPAGANDA MACHINE
GETTING BACK TO THEIR OLD WAYS
TO DEFLECT THE BLAME.
THE EXPERTS WARNED IT IS GOING
TO GET A WHOLE LOT WORSE.
JOE BIDEN WOULD LOVE TO TAKE
CREDIT WHEN THE PRICES WERE
FALLING, BUT NOW THE WHITE HOUSE
IS PASSING THE BUCK AND BLAMING
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> YOU SAID THE PRESIDENT WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR GAS PRICES
COMING DOWN HERE IT IS THE PRICE
RESPONSIBLE FOR GAS PRICES GOING
UP?
>> SO, IT IS A LOT MORE NUANCED
THAN THAT.
THERE HAVE BEEN GLOBAL
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE ALL
DEALT WITH.
THERE HAS BEEN THE PANDEMIC AND
PUTIN'S WAR AND PUTIN'S WAR HAS
INCREASED GAS PRICES AT THE PUMP
APPEARANCE BE FIVE AND NOW
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS LOOKING LIKE
A TOTAL FOOL.
REMEMBER THREE MONTHS AGO IT WAS
SUCKING UP TO THE SAUDIS AND
FIST PUMPING THROUGH THE
MIDDLE EAST BEGGING THEM FOR
MORE OIL?
WELL, THOUGH OPEC CARTEL AT THE
THIS MORNING TO CUT REDUCTION BY
2 MILLION BARRELS A DAY.
SO NOW BIDEN IS GOING TO RELEASE
MORE OIL FROM OUR
DEPLETED, STRATEGIC RESERVES.
ALL RIGHT, JESSE, THAT JUST CAME
OUT THIS AFTERNOON THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO RELEASE
OIL FROM OUR RESERVES AFTER
RELEASE, I GUESS IT WAS
180 MILLION BARRELS NOT THAT
LONG AGO BUT HOW MUCH WILL BE
LEFT OF OUR STRATEGIC OIL?
>> Jesse: IT IS GOING TO BE
DRIED.
HE IS A RECKLESS ECONOMIC
ILLITERATE, AND HE WILL CAUSE A
LOT OF PAIN TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BECAUSE WE WILL NEED
THOSE RESERVES FULL AT SOME
POINT AND BEFORE THAT WE WILL
HAVE TO BUY BACK AND RESTOCK 10.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT WILL DO
TO THE WORLD PRICE OF OIL?
IF HE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND IT IS
SET BY THE WORLD.
HE THINKS, FRED THAT OWNS THE
GAS STATION AT THE CORNERS
THAT'S THE PRICE OF OIL.
IF YOU WILL NOT UNLEASH AMERICAN
INNES DOMESTIC INDUSTRY, YOU
HAVE TO BUTTER UP THE SAUDIS AND
THE BIGGEST ARRAY NANCE,
SCENTING MANY ARMS PACKAGES LIKE
MOST PRESIDENTS DO.
HE CALLED THE CROWN PRINCE A
KILLER AND TRIED TO OSTRACIZE
HIM.
THE GREEN NEW DEAL, THE RENEWED
DEAL AND WE NEED A LITTLE MORE
FINESSE WHEN EVERYBODY IS
GETTING SLAMMED AT THE PUMP.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE GUY IS
ALREADY DEALING WITH
CRIME, INFLATION AND NOW YOU SEE
THE RISING GAS PRICES?
THIS WILL GUARANTEE REPUBLICANS.
>> Judge Jeanine:
JESSICA, ISN'T IT TIME FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE
NEED TO BE ENERGY INDEPENDENT SO
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO BE ON HIS
KNEES TO A GUY THAT HE THINKS IS
A MURDERER AND TO THE
VENEZUELANS?
WHY ARE WE ON BENDED KNEE WHEN
ENERGY INDEPENDENT?
>> Jessica: WE STILL ARE
TECHNICALLY ENERGY INDEPENDENT
DEPENDING ON WHAT KIND OF
AMMUNITION YOU USE.
THERE ARE TWO WAYS TO USE IT IF
YOU MEAN WE DON'T IMPORT OIL, IF
THAT IS YOUR DEFINITION THAT HAS
NOT HAPPENED SINCE THE 1940s.
IF YOUR DEFINITION IS WE EXPORT
MORE THAN IMPORT, 2019 THAT
STARTED UNDER DONALD TRUMP AND
HAS CONTINUED UNDER
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
SO PICK OR CHOOSE WHICH ONE IT
IS.
WE STILL ARE THAT.
>> Jesse: REPORTING STUFF FROM
THE STOCKPILE.
>> Jessica: UNDERSTAND THAT.
DON'T SAY, YEAH.
THERE ARE A LOT OF POLLS
ARGUMENTS FLYING AROUND USING
ENERGY INDEPENDENT LIKE DAN
CRENSHAW, KRISTI NOEM SAYING IF
KEYSTONE HAD GONE THROUGH, WE
WOULD NOT BE IN THIS MESS, BUT
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAID IT
WOULD HAVE MINIMAL IMPACT HOW
MUCH GAS WE HAVE BECAUSE IT IS
DEPENDENT UPON GLOBAL MARKETS,
WHICH IS THE POINT THAT CRENSHAW
IS TRYING TO MAKE ABOUT THIS.
EVERYBODY IS SUFFERING FROM
THESE PROBLEMS.
YES, HE DIDN'T GO THERE AND TRY
TO GET THE SAUDIS TO BACK OFF OF
THE SPIRIT IT IS EMBARRASSING.
THAT THEY THEN MOVED AHEAD AND
MADE THE CUT.
BUT PLAYING AROUND SAYING ENERGY
INDEPENDENT WITHOUT EXPLAINING
WHAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT IS A
FALSE ARGUMENT.
>> Judge Jeanine: ALL RIGHT,
GREG WE PAID $2 FOR GAS WHEN
TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT.
BE PAID AS MUCH AS $6 NOW IN
CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T CARE WHAT YOUR
DEFINITION OF ANYTHING IS AT
THIS POINT.
ALL I KNOW IS IT IS MORE NOW.
WHY IS THAT?
>> Greg: ARE NO
ECONOMISTS, JUDGE BUT THIS WOULD
NOT HAVE HAPPENED UNDER TRUMP
AND I KNOW THAT SOUNDS EXTREMELY
STEREOTYPICAL BUT THE FACT
IS I KNOW THIS IS A TERRIBLE
DEAL AND JOE WENT THERE ON HIS
KNEES AND THEY JUST SCREWED HIM.
I DON'T SEE THAT HAPPENING
WITH -- ACTUALLY I WOULD BROADEN
AND SAY I DON'T SEE IT HAPPENING
WITH TRUMP OR ANYBODY ELSE.
IT JUST SO HAPPENED IT HAPPENED
TO BIDEN.
THAT IS KIND OF STRANGE.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY CURES IT
IS LABELED PUTIN 'PRICE HIKE.
THAT LAD.
NO, THEY REALIZE AND IDEOLOGY OF
FOOT REGARDLESS OF THE REALITY
NOW.
IDEOLOGY THAT STATED THIS WOULD
BE GOOD FOR US IF WE GOT OFF
OIL.
SO YOU ARE OKAY TO BE SUSPICIOUS
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS ACTUALLY
TRYING TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
WHEN IT FACT, THE PROBLEM IS A
SOLUTION.
AND YOU TALK ABOUT GAS PRICES
GOING UP, IT IS STILL NOT AS
EXPENSIVE AS AN ELECTRIC CAR.
IT IS STILL NOT AS EXPENSIVE AS
A EXPENSIVE AS ELECTRICITY FOR
AN ELECTRIC CAR.
I HAVE TO SAY PETE, OUR OWN
PETE.
DOUBLE ZERO PETE.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW THIS WITH JP
WHENEVER SHE BEGINS A SENTENCE
WITH SO, THAT MEANS EVERYTHING
TO THE RIGHT OF SO IS NOT TRUE.
BECAUSE IT IS LIKE SO IS
BASICALLY, WHAT IT DOES IS
REDEFINE THE ANSWER INTO A
DIFFERENT KIND OF I DON'T KNOW
WORD SALAD.
SO SHE WENT SO...
AND THEN SHE WENT LIKE THIS.
>> Judge Jeanine:
LOOKED, DANICA WERE IN THAT
POSITION WITH KARINE JEAN-PIERRE
RIGHT NOW.
WHEN )) TAKES CREDIT FOR PRICES
GOING DOWN BUT NOT UP BUT SHE
SAYS, SO, THE NUANCE IN
FACT, I MEAN HOW COME SHE
DOESN'T ANSWER THE QUESTION AND
ONLY 5%.
>> Dana: THE FACT IS A BAD
ANSWER, RIGHT?
IT IS LIKE EVEN THE STOCK
MARKET.
IF THE PRESIDENT GOES AROUND
STATING "LOOK AT ME."
MY GOODNESS A STOCK MARKET AND
WHEN IT IS NOW, I HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH THAT.
THAT IS NOT BELIEVABLE FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT FEELS REALLY LIKE POLITICS
AND IT IS BAD APPEAR THE OTHER
THINK THIS ADMINISTRATION
DOESN'T AT THAT AND IT IS BECAUF
THE WORK WITH THE IRANIANS
AND THE POLICE HAVE THE STRATEGC
PETROLEUM RESERVE, BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS HAVE PUSHED THE SAUDIS
CLOSER TO RUSSIA AND CHINA.
AND SO, THAT POLICY IS PLAYING
OUT WHILE THEY ARE ALSO REFUSING
WHEN TRUMP WAS IN OFFICE, HE HAD
THIS DEAL.
HE SAID, "WE CAN REPEAL THE
PETROLEUM RESERVE $4 A BARREL.
WE SHOULD TAKE THAT DEAL."
ARE WE ARE NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING.
WE ARE LOOKING AT $100 A BARREL.
AND IT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
EMERGENCY RESERVES AND THEY ARE
RELEASING IT TODAY.
HERE IS HOW WE WILL HELP YOU GET
THROUGH THE